[موسيقى]
ا اهلا
بكم تخيلوا لو انني شخص ذو قوه ذو سلط
واطلب منكم ان اقنعكم بان تاخذوا قرارا
معينا نحو امر
ما الى اي مدى ستث بهذه
الرساله او تخيل لو انك لا قدر الله
اضطررت لان تتصل بالاسعاف لاي طارئ ما
اتصلت بالاسعاف وانت خائف وانت مرتبك ولا
تعرف ما تقول فيرد عليك مستقبل المكالمات
وهو بذات الارتباك بذات الخوف ويعطيك ايما
اجابه على اي شيء تريد ان تتحدث
عنه الى اين قد تؤول هذه
المكالمه لو تفكرنا
للحظات لوجدت ان صوتك هو اول ما يعينك
واول شيء يعبر عنك منذ اول لحظه
لك منذ الساعات الاولى في الولاده او بعد
الولاده اصرخ فنعرف انك على قيد
الحياه بعدها باشهر قليله تعرف امك انك
تسمع جيدا من
صوتك تصدر صوتا فنعرف انك تتالم صوت اخر
فتعرف انك جائع
مثلا تكبر اكثر في هذه الحياه وتعرف ربما
ان الصراخ يكون للتعبير عن
الغضب وان السعاده والحماس لهما صوت
يميزهما
وهكذا طوال مسيرتك تدرك ان هذه الاله هي
سبيلك الاول للتعبير الصحيح عن ماجول
بخاطرك بل ووسيلته الاهم لايصال
رسائلك اخذت على عاتقي ان اعرف اسرار هذه
الاله العجيبه وقررت اليوم ان اعطيكم بعضا
من هذه الاسرار لنتمكن
جميعا اول هذه الاسرار عرفتها عندما خفت
عندما
توترت اذكر في اول تجربه اذاعيه لي قبل
الهواء مباشره بثلاث دقائق لاقت الصوت
امامي بعد ثلاث دقائق سيسمي
الجميع وقتها من التوتر شعرت حرفيا وان
دقات قلبي موجوده هنا في
حنجرتي وقتها تخيلت وان صوتي من سيسمع ص
صوتي سيشعر وكانني لتوي شخص قد ركض لعشره
اميال لكن قلت لنفسي يا بنت قوي قلبك انت
تدربين على الصوت وقد كان ماذا
فعلت اخذت نفس وعليه اطلب منكم جميعا ان
تركزوا معي للحظات وناخذ هذا النفس
سويا خذ شهيقا لاربع
ثواني احبسه لاربع
ثواني زفير لاربع
ثواني ثم احبسه لاربع
ثواني مره
اخرى
وهكذا مره بعد مره ستلاحظ الهدوء على جسدك
كله وتلقائيا سيظهر هذا الهدوء على
صوتك وقتها قمت بعمل عه في اربعه
وصدقوني كان مفعوله
سحرا
وحقيقه لم يقف صوتي عن خدمتي الى هذا الحد
بل خدمني وخدم كل واحد منكم على مدار
حياته في مواقف عديده
مثلا مثلا تخيل لو ان هناك شخصا يتحدث
امام حشد كبير من الناس وهو يتحدث ويتحدث
وصوته مرتفع بهذه
الطريقه ودك تقول للا عندك
مايك هذا الشخص فعليا اصواته
الداخليه مرتفعه اكثر من صوته الداخلي
رهبه التحدث الخوف من حكم الاخرين وغيرها
وغيرها الكثير
ولو
انك عدلت من كل
ذلك تمكنت مما عندك تدربت كثيرا ل نعكس ما
بداخلك على
خارجك واصبحت في المره القادمه اذا استمعت
الى شخص او اذا كنت انت الشخص الذي يقف
على خشبه مسرح ويتحدث امام حجد كبير من
الناس لا يخيل اليك انه يجب عليك ان تسمع
الاخرين كلهم ولكن تخيلهم شخصا واحدا
امامك هل سترتفع من صوتك ام ستبقي على هذه
النبره
الواثقه هذا الصوت ايضا يعتبر سر من اسرار
التربيه منكم اباء وامهات ويعرفون ذلك في
المره القادمه اذا قام ولدك بعمل اي شيء
خاطئ لا تصرخ عليه ولكن ارفع صوتك قليلا
عن الحد المعتاد ليعرف ان هناك خطب
ما اذا لم يكن ارفعه
اكثر
وهكذا سيفعل ما تريد وسيكون لديك مساحه
اكثر في صوتك لان ترتفع
به دون ان يكون الصراخ هو الامر
المعتاد هناك الكثير من الاشخاص من تحدثون
بهذه الطريقه طوال الوقت وفي حديثهم عن اي
موضوع عن اي شيء ما سواء كان مهم او سوالف
عاديه او اي شيء اخر يرد ان نتحدث فيه مع
الاخرين وهذا ما يسمى بالمونو تون او
الرتابه
الصوتيه اين تكمن خطر الرتابه الصوتيه
وبالمناسبه كثير منكم في هذه القاعه قد ي
قد يكون لديه صوت رتيب ولا يعرف ذلك الا
اذا سجل صوته عبر تسجيل صوتي وبالمناسبه
من منكم يكره ان يستمع الى صوته المسجل
جميل ايادي مرتفعه هذه هي الفكره اين تكمن
خطر الرتابه خطر الرتابه يكمن في انك
عندما تتحدث عن امر معين طوال وقت وايا
كان حديثك ايا كان الموضوع وانت تتحدث
بهذه الطريقه طوال الوقت ارتفاعا وانخفاضا
او انخفاضا وارتفاعا سيكون صوتك بوتيره
واحده وبالتالي من يستمع اليك بعد فتره من
الزمن سيفقد اهتمامه بحديثك وسيركز انه في
الجمله القادمه سيرتفع سينخفض
وهكذا ضاعت
رسالتك اذا ماذا نفعل لنتخلص من الرتابه
الصوتيه هنا كان
السر
الثالث عش
الشعور اذكر في احد المرات تحدثت مع ممثل
المسرحي قال لي عندما كان مدربه يدربه على
اداء صوت او اداء شعور معين كالخوف
مثلا طلب منه ان
يجلس ان يغمض عينه ان يمد يده لمجسم امامه
ويتخيل ان هذا المجسم هو اعز شخص
عليه لكنه
ميت على قساوه هذا التخيل لكن دعونا نحلل
هذا الموقف منطقيا متى ما تخيلت هذا
الموقف عقلك يرسل الاشارات لذاكرتك ان
يبحث هنا وهناك عن موضوع معين عن موقف
مشابه لشعور مشابه وبالتالي متى ما وصل
الى هذا الموقف الى هذا الشعور سيظهر على
جسمك قد
تتاثر قد تدمع
عينك ومن المؤكد ان يظهر هذا على
صوتك اذكر في احد الانشطه الطلابيه التي
قمت بها هنا في جامعه قطر كنا نتحدث او
طلب مني ان اقدم خطابا ما هذا الخطاب كنت
احكي فيه قصه ما اقول فيها كان فريقي
مبتدئا نوعا ما وكانت المناظره النهائيه
ضد اعتق واقوى الفرق وكانت النتيجه اننا
فزنا وقتها شعرت بسعاده بالغه حيث اننا
المبتدئون فزنا على اقوى الفرق وقتها
اوقفني مرشدي كان شخص يرشدني امامي قال لي
لحظه لحظه هذه الجمله التي قلتيها فيها
اربع مشاعر
مختلفه قلت
بنبره واحده قلت لهش دخل شلون قال لي نعم
انا مراتك وهي هذه الفكره عندما نتحدث عن
الاداء يجب علينا ان نتخذ شخصا يكون مراه
لنا يعرف جيدا ما يقول يسلط الضوء على
نقاط القوه ونقاط
التحسين بعد التعديل حددنا الشعور المطلوب
ووصلنا الى هذه
النتيجه كان فريقي مبتدئا نوعا ما تقليل
شان وكانت المناظره النهائيه ضد اعتق
واقوى الفرق تكبير تعظيم رهبه وكانت
النتيجه ترقب اننا فزنا عدم تصديق وقتها
شعرت بسعاده بغه حيث اننا المبتدئون فزنا
على اقوى
الفرق
اذا حدد
الشعور تخيله عشه ثم طبقه ليظهر على
صوتك
طب طبعا الان لديك صوت خالي من الخوف لديك
شعور تتخيل يظهر صوتك ولديك صوت التمكين
امورك طيبه وتشعر انك ستخرج الان من هذه
القاعه باسرار الصوت ابشرك ليس بعد هناك
امر اخير
واحد
اسكت يعني ان تصمت
قليلا تخيل لو انني طوال هذا الخطاب منذ ع
دقائق الى الان وانا اتحدث معكم عن الصوت
وعن اشياء كثيره اخرى عن مهارات تتعلمها
في صوتك وانا لم اقف حتى هذه اللحظه ولو
لمره
واحده استخرج من هذا المدرج وراسك كبر هال
المسرح غير مستوعب لما
تقول في حين ان الصمت يساعدك
اولا ساخذ
نفس يقوم عنك بمهمه تقسيم
حديثك والاهم من هذا كله يعطي لهؤلاء
المساكين فرصه لان يستوعبوا ما
تقول
اذا لكم ثانيه سيخدم اكثر مما
تظن بكل هذه الاسرار وغيرها كنت انا احسان
الامس هذه الاسرار التي تعلمتها واتقنت
الى حد كبير اوصلتني لاماكن كثيره اوصلتني
مثلا لان اكون مذيعه اخبار رسميه اوصلتني
لان اخذ كاس واثنين على مستوى الدوله في
الخطابه وغيرها وغيرها الكثير لكن كل هذا
الوقت كنت اقول لنفسي جميل لبابه كل هذا
امر رائع لك انت فقط للباب وماذا
بعد وهنا ومن هذه الفكره اخذت من غرفتي
وبابسط
الامكانات فتحت منصه تطل على العالم ومن
غرفتي كنت اقول سلام ونبر نقول لتصل هذه
الجمله لاكثر من 10 ملايين مشاهد يستمعون
الى كل هذه النصائح ليطبق اوها على صوتهم
ايا كانت مهنتهم ان كنت دكتور طالب محاضر
مسؤول مدير تنفيذي اب ام ايا كنت في هذه
الحياه لتدرك اي ما
ادراك ان هذا المصنع هو اداتك الوحيده
وادات الاهم لتوصل رسائلك لابعد مما تظن
لتكون انت وهم احسان الغد
اليك